gibt immer viel zu besprechen und die
sicherheits expertin claudia mayor von
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
ist wieder bei uns morgen komme ja in
dieser woche wird der krieg in der
ukraine 100 tage alt wo stehen wir in
diesen tagen ich glaube die wichtigste
information ist das glaube ich keiner
gedacht hatte dass der krieg so lange
dauern würde am anfang sah es so aus als
würde die ukraine in wenigen tagen
überrannt werden und die gute nachricht
ist die ukraine wieder steht seit drei
monaten auch dank der westlichen
unterstützung auch der waffenlieferungen
und russland hat sich deutlich
schlechter geschlagen als viele erwartet
haben das heißt natürlich ist der krieg
noch sehr hart und sehr brutal im osten
der ukraine
aber es ist russland nicht gelungen das
land als eigenständigen staat
auszuwischen das hatten sich die russen
sicherlich auch anders vorgestellt sie
haben gesagt sie konzentrieren sich
jetzt auf den osten und es scheint ja so
zu sein als könnten die russen dort auch
land gewinne machen und es scheint zu
sein so zu sein dass sie dort erfolg
haben sind denn die russen dort jetzt
schlafe schlagkräftiger als als bisher
also sie konzentrieren sich gerade auf
den ob lässt auf den obersten lohans
also einen teil des don buses und sie
versuchen jetzt mit der stadt herbert
oder netz die letzte große stadt
einzunehmen um zu sagen können wir haben
den gesamten oblast eingenommen man muss
es aber einordnen muss sagen diese
geländegewinne die sie jetzt gemacht
haben in den letzten tagen haben waren
enorm zerstörerisch also mit einer
enormen brutalität und sie haben
wirklich ihre gesamten kräfte und das
material darauf konzentriert das heißt
sie sind nicht so stark wie es nach
außen aussieht und das ist wirklich ein
sehr begrenzter regionale erfolg in don
was der ukrainische präsident ali hat
erstmals seit kriegsbeginn diese region
besucht in der ost ukraine die umkämpfte
region um charkiw und er hat ja für juni
eine gegenoffensive angekündigt im osten
kann die ukraine da was ausrichten also
tatsächlich gehen viele experten davon
aus dass das momentan so eine art
kulminationspunkt ist und dass danach
wahrscheinlich die russische armee so
geschwächt sein wird dass eine
ukrainische offensive bessere chancen
hätte zumal viel von dem westlichen
material also die haubitzen und all die
anderen sachen über die wir gerade reden
also diese westlichen aus
rüstungslieferungen die kommen jetzt
erst an das heißt die ukrainische armee
kann dadurch nochmal fundamental
gestärkt werden und daher ist die
hoffnung dass eine ukrainische
gegenoffensive im sommer größere
erfolgschancen hätte es gab eine
interessante aussage in diesen tagen vom
russischen außenminister lawrow versagte
die einnahme des donners also dort im
osten der ukraine sei bedingungslose
priorität aber und das ist noch
interessanter die anderen gebiete der
ukraine müssten die bewohner in den
anderen gebieten der ukraine müssten die
bewohner selbst über ihre zukunft
entscheiden also kann das sein dass die
russen da so eine tür aufschlagen zu
einer möglichen diplomatischen lösung
ich würde es eher anders lesen ich würde
eher sagen dass russland sich momentan
auf den don was konzentriert weil sie
eigentlich nur dazu in der lage sind das
aber das übergeordnete ziel was hinter
dem ganzen krieg stand nämlich die
eigene staatlichkeit der ukraine in
frage zu stellen und die ukraine als
eigenständigen staat abzuschaffen dass
das nicht aufgegeben worden ist und dann
so ein bisserl im hintergrund getreten
ist und russland versucht es einerseits
militärisch zu machen im bass und auch
der landbrücke im süden und es versucht
das über so eine absolut politischen
lösungen so etwas vorzuschlagen wenn man
sich das russische vorgehen gerade im
süden an sieht mario pohl oder person
versucht russland fakten zu schaffen in
dem russland auf russisch muss noch
gesprochen wird in dem die
telefonnummern beispielsweise auf
russland umgestellt werden an dem der
google als zahlungsmittel eingeführt
wird also sie schaffen schon fakten ohne
irgendwie zu verhandeln in diesen
gebieten aber könnte das eine lösung
sein der frühere amerikanische
außenminister kissinger hat ja in davos
auch diesen vorschlag gemacht und wurde
dafür sehr kritisiert die krippe abgeben
möglicherweise im osten gebiete abgeben
und dadurch eine einigung erzielen ich
glaube dass das die falsche
herangehensweise ist die ukraine ist ein
souveräner staat sie entscheidet was mit
ihr passiert zu glauben dass man
einzelne landstücke opfern könnte und
dass dadurch frieden wäre ist ein
irrglaube das zeigt die fanden die
russische politik der vergangenen jahre
russland hat die krim annektiert 2014 es
gibt trotzdem diesen krieg das heißt zu
glauben man könnte damit die russische
zu sagen die russische russischen willen
befriedigen halte ich für absolut
gefährlich wir sehen vielmehr an den
äußerungen der russischen regierung
ansonsten dass sie von dem ziel nicht
abgewichen sind dass ihr die ukraine
eigentlich
kontrollieren wollen und dass in der
ukraine die eigene identität absprechen
also ich glaube dass das größten
stürmern über vielen dank für das
interview wir immer interessante und
kluge einschätzungen von der sicherheits
expertin claudia dankeschön gerne